[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: Hi, and welcome
back to the Developer Shows
coverage at GDD India.
I'm Dan Gaplin here talking
to Nasir Khan about running
in the background on Android.
Now, Nasir, what do
you mean when you
say running in the background?
NASIR KHAN: As I
said in my talk,
it could mean different things
to different developers.
It could mean running
off the main thread,
running on a background thread.
It would also mean running
a background service
or running off a broadcast
receiver being called.
Or it could mean
reacting to FCM method.
It could mean different things.
DAN GALPIN: Isn't this
a problem that's been,
you know, really well solved?
NASIR KHAN: You're
right, it's been solved.
It's been solved in
many different ways,
and there are many use cases and
[INAUDIBLE] already out there.
But Android platform
also has been changing.
The first changes
were introduced
in Marshmallow and [INAUDIBLE].
And over time, there have
been progressive changes
which have been changing the
way background processing works.
The most significant of them
has been the Oreo background
restrictions on
free-running services
and implicit broadcasts.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
how does Android O
change, then, what
developers have to consider?
NASIR KHAN: So I
think you must have
heard of [INAUDIBLE] background
restrictions in Oreo.
I would like to call it an
opportunity for developers
to take a step back
and look at their apps
and see how they can optimize
their app to be more battery
efficient with these changes.
DAN GALPIN: Is there
anything that O
is offering that can
actually help developers?
NASIR KHAN: Actually it is.
So there have been
changes on one hand
to restrict the
background services.
But on the other hand, we are
introducing new constructs
like a job intern service,
which actually makes it really,
really easy for developers to
write the similar kind of code
they were writing
before, but handle it
in a way which is better
handled on all devices.
So that, and also
there have been
new changes in the
scheduler API as well,
where they can actually see
more new constraints, like
does the device
have enough storage?
Does the device have
enough battery to run?
So they can be more mindful
of the device state as well.
DAN GALPIN: Well, that's great.
Now, where can developers
go to learn more
about the changes
in O and how to help
adapt what their apps are doing?
NASIR KHAN: I would
say they should
start at developer.android.com.
There is a lot of narrative
documentation around it.
There's also good
reference [INAUDIBLE]
that has been recently
updated in these areas.
They can also refer
to some block code
that we wrote around
background restrictions lately.
DAN GALPIN: Thank you,
Nasir, for joining us today.
Now visit the description
below if you'd
like to find out more
about background processing
on Android and Android O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]